نحن هنا داخل مطار جيبوتي الدولي الذي
اصبح محطه انظار العالم منذ اندلاع الازمه
في السودان اصبح ممرا
لعبور
الرعايه الاجانب الذين اجلوا من السودان
كما ترون ورائي مباشره هناك طائرات عسكريه
بعضها تابعه للصين وبعضها لدول اخرى وعلى
يساري هناك طائره عسكريه يبدو انها هي
تابعه للحكومه الفرنسيه وايضا تمت طائره
اخرى لليابانيه كل هذه الطائرات وغيرها
التي ترابط في مطار جيبوتي الدولي هي في
انتظار اجلال الاجانب العالقين في السودان
مطار جيبوتي الدولي استقبل عدد كبير من
الرعايه الاجانب الذين تم اجلائهم من
السودان غالبيتهم من الاتحاد الاوروبي ومن
امريكا ومن الصين ومن المانيا كلهم مروا
هذا المطار ولا زال العمل عمليات الاجلاء
جاريه في هذا المطار نحن الان في هذا
الساعه بالتحديد الحركه ليست قويه لكن في
فترات المساء تنشط الحركه اكثر ويصبح هذا
المطار وكانه سكن عسكريه بمحيط مطار
جيبوتي الدولي هناك قواعد عسكريه كثيره
بعضها تابعه للولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وبعضها الاخر لالمانيا وبعضها الاخر هي في
منطقه قريبه من من المطار اي ايضا تابعه
للصين وللدول الاسكندنافيه اخرى كله هذه
الدول ادخلت قواعدها العسكريه هذه
حاله التاهب القصوى لاجلال رعاياها من
السودان في ظل هذه الازمه التي يعيشها
السودان وربما تنظر بعض الدول التي
لها قواعد عسكريه وغيرها ممن لديهم رعايه
لا زالوا عالقين داخل السودان يعلقون
امالا كبيره على الهدنه التي تم الاعلان
عنها لعلهم يستطيعون اجلاء رعاياهم من
هناك